sur ce plateau douglas y ait ce
professeur en droit et spécialiste de la
politique américaine de la science
politique américaine bon joueur douglas
y ait merci d'être avec nous joe biden
vient donc de s'exprimer
est ce que c'est le grand gagnant de ces
primaires de ce super tuesday
même si on sent que bernie sanders est
en embuscade oui jo byden c'est le
retour au nom marie s'est donc permis
sanders et joe barton semblait deux
hommes les plus connus est évidemment le
retour au centre c'est le grand nouvelle
d'aujourd'hui on peut ni ça ne se trouve
un peu isolé parce que tous les
candidats de centre ont soutenu byden et
la machine de parti démocrate à
fonctionner très bien dans les états du
sud la rue et nous envoient des noix
américaine quand vous dites c'est du
centre soutiennent joe biden on pense
notamment à petit budget nous a mis le
budget requis sont retirés en faveur de
joe biden oui exactement le centre était
/ parmi plusieurs candidates jo by day
in club
charpy budget mais aussi michael
bloomberg est en aveux dans un sondage
que qu'ils ont voté pour michael
bloomberg
hier on dit qu'ils vont soutenir byden
si blue bird démission il va se retirer
selon vous un michael green dragon
rappelle qu'il a investi 500 millions
d'euros dans la publicité de sa fortune
personnelle
oui pour l'instant je pense il n'a pas
l'entrée parce que c'est vrai il a déjà
pris leur est pas donc ils veulent le
manger c'est un peu profité en aveux 14
% des gens soutiennent sans vraiment en
campagne mais juste les publicités mais
un des résultats de super tuesday
montrent que sans une vraie campagne de
fond sans le porte à porte sans les
volontaires les résultats n'étaient pas
là pour l'instant huit états ont
ont livré leur verdict qu'il en reste
encore quelques-uns
est-ce que selon vous les avantages joe
biden va se confirmer on sait qu'elle
texas notamment qui doit livrer son
verdict prochainement
ou est-ce que bernie sanders peut
revenir sur
sur joe biden concernant ces 14 et à un
texte peut-être pas mais en californie
si donc california et ses fameuses mans
la gauche dans le parti démocrate
hollywood en scène francis cors et
bernie sanders a pris 1 avant ce bail
den dans les résultats du tout ce matin
natixis peut-être pas en tant que
suspect peut-être bail de neuf ans se
souder son statut comme leader mais ce
qui est certain c'est maintenant un an
bataille entre le parti de gauche et le
parti de droite le parti démocrate s'est
divisé et ça ne va pas démissionner
jusqu'à la convention il a plein des
délicates
même si pareille devienne le leader
donc on l'a bien compris il va rester
puisqu'il a priori elisabeth roy rené
michael bloomberg devrait se désister
prochainement en faveur de joe biden
donc on devrait avoir une course à deux
entre joe biden qui est lui plus dire le
centriste la droite des démocrates et
bernie sanders qui se prétendant
socialiste le sénateur du vermont non
plus la gauche des démocrates dans ce
duel jusqu'à la fin est-ce qu'il ya déjà
des sondages qui qui donne des premiers
indices pour savoir lequel des deux
pourrait affronter donald trump
prochainement et lequel serait mieux
placé justement pour affronter donald
trump
oui les difficultés dans un scrutin au
premiertour sait il faut faire les
sondages où on demande si quelqu'un
démission qui va vous soutenir aussi un
peu moins concrètes dans un bois à deux
tours donc les sondages on dit depuis le
début que brise un 12/20 se battre dans
l'autre en mai le problème ces sondages
sont national et l'élection joue étape
par étape est donc maintenant le
sensibilité cette ambiance ce sentiment
que beaucoup des démocrates en choisir
byden c'est que byden peuvent
rattraper les voix du centre parce qu'on
tient de la drogue ni ni démocrates ni
républicain et c'est ça quand tu joues
le voir ea dont on est prégnant en droit
vers la gauche vers la droite
on ne rattrape les extrêmes mais dès
qu'on arrive dans le vrai bataille
l'élection uninominal une chasse le
sandre et tout le monde croit que
bernier battre là et pour ça ils voient
ils ôtent stratégiquement pour baden
vous dit tout le monde croit on sait
qu'il y avait eu des sondages en 2016
qui donnait on va dire plus hillary
clinton vainqueur finalement c'était la
surprise donald trump les américains ne
croient plus en la surprise par exemple
bernie sanders a oui ou non il y a plein
les gens on a fait un sondage premier
les jeunes exemple et prenez les lieux
et on ne voit que les gens sont prêts à
voter pour quelqu'un qui se rassemblent
dans les idées dans les politiques
pendant que les démocrates plus âgés
préfèrent voter quelqu'un qui peut
gagner qui peuvent se battre dans
l'autre hélas la division est là et les
jeunes voient moins souvent que leurs
aînés pas forcément sur des primaires
démocrates on a parlé des démocrates
mais une dernière question sur les
républicains comment les républicains
voient ça de l'extérieur
cette lutte ou
démocrate oui sont contents parce qu'ils
croient que le candidat qui indifférence
mais doperait aline lightman l'homme le
l'historienne qui a bien de prédire tous
les élections rétrospectivement depuis
lundi c'est que c'est pas le candidat
qui compte c'est le parti et on peut
voir plus proche le corno diori si son
affect sur l'économie que qui est le
candidat démocrate qui provient de
contrat le candidat républicaine merci
beaucoup de blessés y est d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes professeur de droit et
spécialiste en sciences politiques
américaines